so the federal government made a big
whoopsie today and uh apparently got
caught trying to destroy evidence in the
proud boys January 6 case it's a very
crazy story but apparently the evidence
we don't know exactly what it was but we
know that one of these agents said they
were instructed to destroy evidence and
remove an individual's involvement from
the evidence meaning there were
according to this agents involved in
January 6 at least that's the evidence
they destroyed I'm gonna go ahead and
assume that it is 100 True considering
they tried to destroy the evidence and
we only caught the records of the
destruction I wonder what they were
destroying and why
because of this one defendant in the in
the case is now demanding a mistrial so
we'll talk about that plus we got
another crazy story this one is a
congressional testimony from Matt taibi
and Michael schellenberger
this is really interesting we've got a
new Twitter files showing that there was
an attempt to censor true information
according to these documents true
information that could cause vaccine
hesitancy that throws all of their
arguments out the window it's not about
misinformation malinformation or
disinformation they quite literally were
saying behind the scenes they intended
to shut down the truth
so before we get into all that head over
to timcast.com click that join us button
and become a member ladies and gentlemen
I only get one day a year to really
Hammer this in and I know I've been
promoting it throughout the week because
I'll I'll take what I can get but it's
my birthday
so if you want to give me a birthday
present go to timcast.com click join us
become a member support our work we rely
on your memberships to keep this
operation afloat add ads are not a big
portion of our Revenue you got to
understand activists come after you in
this way they try and shut your business
down but the more members we get the
more uncensorable we become
so do that also you'll find in the
description below a link to pre-order
our new song Bright Eyes which is coming
out I believe March 24th we put up a
pre-order link we'll probably take the
promotion of it much more seriously as
the as the days and weeks move closer to
the as we get closer to the release date
but uh bandcamp the website that hosted
our music not all of it we have other
websites that we use deleted our account
as well as five times August and I
believe also Bryson gray and the reason
is they desperately fear us getting
involved in the culture game because
that's how you win a culture war with
culture so you can support our work and
pre-order the song in with the link in
the description below smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the share with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about this and so much
more we got Jack besobic well Tim I'd
just like to thank you for being so
inclusive and allowing federal agents
like myself to join the Pod uh the
fattiest fed the glowiest glow worm of
them all yes here I am and and I'd like
to let you know that in addition to
hosting human events daily everything
that I'm wearing right now comes from
mypillow.com is it is that true that's
actually true the shirt and everything
this is my pillow sweet sleepwear these
are the my pillow pants pajamas on the
shoes and oh yes ladies and gentlemen
okay I have some of those the my
slippers those are actually really great
it is like wearing little pillows
attached to your feet with every step
you walk on liberal tears you actually
cannot be upset while wearing your pair
of mice I actually do a pair of those I
ordered a couple for me and my
girlfriend they're actually really
really nice I I actually love them yeah
you you it's it's like having a little
pillow so every step you're like oh wow
that's great ridiculously soft so nice
all right jack thanks for hanging out
and uh we also are joined by Jack's bus
yeah technically
I don't think that's true yeah I'm the
editor-in-chief of human events oh and
the post-millennial so it's actually
very exciting and I get to work with
Jack all the time which is awesome right
on well there you go we got Phil Labonte
hanging out Ian's taking the night off
hello I am philibonti lead singer of All
That Remains anti-communist and
counter-revolutionary
Serge yo I am at surge.com how are you
guys hope you're well all right let's
jump into this first story ladies and
gentlemen in what may be one of the most
shocking revelations from January 6 thus
far
Julie Kelly who is just on this show
this past week says breaking drama and
the proud boys trial yesterday after FBI
agent caught lying on the stand and
concealing evidence from defense
attorneys not only that
the messages the long story short of it
this agent thought they were deleting
messages from their what is it called
the link system the link system yeah and
they were actually just putting them
like a hidden tab which the defense
found and were like wow you lied about
all this and there's even messages where
they say things like delete the I I've
been ordered to destroy evidence this
one's really important one message says
an agent made a request to special agent
Miller to quote go into a a CHS
informant report that Miller just put
together and edit out that the agent was
present so hold on there a minute this
is a January 6th seditious conspiracy
case for the proud boys and there was a
special agent there there was some kind
of federal agent present with these
people
oh that's it that's evidence of federal
involvement right there now here's the
crazy thing the story from Politico says
this assistant U.S attorney Jocelyn
Ballentine who is supervising the case
for the justice department acknowledged
the likely spill of classified
information Thursday morning she raised
particular concerns about a message sent
to Miller by another agent who works on
Covert activity
and who said she did not work on the
Proud boys case oh yeah I believe that
describing a supervisor's order to quote
destroy
338 items of evidence oh that's a huge
number of evidence destroying any
evidence
listen up folks listen up folks I've
I've been instructed by my uh by my
friends down in Washington DC to let you
know that those pieces of evidence were
totally immaterial you don't need to
worry about those 338 or the 400 excuse
me 338 pieces of evidence that were
destroyed don't even ask any questions
by the way I love the fact that they
wrote down they wrote in an email oh by
the way my boss told me to destroy all
this evidence like if you're going to
delete your evidence don't go ahead and
you know write an email with somebody
about it if you're gonna do something
illegal don't tell people you're doing
it you know there's a line in the wire
of that and it's it's Stringer Bell and
he's like are you taking notes on a
criminal conspiracy and it grabs the
notepad and tears it up you know I I'm
kind of worried that we're sitting here
all laughing having a good old time
meanwhile this is direct evidence of the
the utmost government corruption the the
reason I mean these guys are being
tortured how long has this been going on
I mean when we see this kind of
corruption when we see this kind of
definitely illegal activity of
destroying evidence how long has the
government been behaving this way has it
been the whole time is it only recently
I would assume probably the past hundred
years probably the whole Jekyll Island
and who was it uh Wilson yeah I mean I
think I mean Hamilton was pretty
nefarious it's like the government would
ever lie to us about like you know
something like a war at this level but
it's sort of shocking to like
continuously be made aware of the fact
that the government is yeah they were
founded by Jared Hoover no but it's like
at this level like to this level I
really think that it's something that's
probably come in the past 15 years like
this level this level yeah because
because of how much how much information
we all just openly put out on the
internet there's also been like how easy
it is to monitor us that's I think that
that this is fairly new there's probably
been the desire you you do have the FBI
wiretapping and stuff in the past but I
think that it's probably 15 years has
really been you know since the Snowden
revolutions were ever Revelations were
what 10 years ago now I think so 10
years this year yeah you know 15 maybe
20 years there's been an increase I
think since Obama in like General
trusting the government too well so so I
I think it's I think it's a little both
because I do think there's a part of it
that's been going on from the start but
I I I think what's more powerful now and
and Elon has actually been been talking
about this is that now we have the
ability to share this information and we
have the ability to talk about these
things directly uh in ways that like we
can live tweet from inside a federal
courtroom about what's going on and then
that gets shared at Mass scale because
of Twitter and then the people behind
the scenes would have to be able to
respond to that versus you know a cub
reporter writing that up and it goes in
some local paper somewhere now we have
the ability with distributed networks to
actually be able to share it very
quickly number two be because of the
Patriot Act and the high level of
technological sophistication that that
Snowden and others have been able to to
prove and and show to us and people I
used to work with at the fort
they become very stupid right so they're
they're extremely powerful but they
don't need to be sophisticated anymore
so you you get these dumb levels of
operations that never seem to go
anywhere or these stupid cover stories
like this Nordstrom 2 thing oh no it was
it was this pro-ukrainian group and they
just expect everybody to run with that
because back in the day that's how it
used to work they would just hand
something to the New York Times New York
Times would be the operation Mockingbird
yeah the New York Times would print it
and then everybody would just go off of
that because that's the paper of record
meanwhile nowadays you can be on Twitter
and actually go in and say wait a minute
like I know a guy in Denmark and he says
that he was near the pier the night that
that happened and this is what he saw
and so instead of this uh or post a
video of it or and post a video of it I
actually said that
the night of the bin Laden raid
um you can actually go back and find
that the most significant thing that
happened that night in 2011 wasn't
necessarily that the United States
government conducted a covert operation
okay that happens but it was that there
was a Pakistani guy excuse me um yeah no
Pakistan Pakistan guy down the street
live tweeting it yeah he said hey a
helicopter just flew over my house hey
there's guys getting out hey there's all
these explosions in gunfire what's going
on he's live tweeting yeah he's actually
live tweeting the bin Laden I I hope the
threat is still up somewhere live
tweeting the operation in real time I
said that's the future right there
that's the future because now I think it
was
I want to say it was Christopher
Hitchens or somebody uh said this
recently um or you know brought this up
recently that he said he said I don't
read newspapers and he said well why
don't he read newspapers well because I
know people in these various Industries
and therefore I get the information
before the newspaper that's Twitter
that's social media well yeah local news
can become National in seconds to uh to
a to a certain degree the federal
government is attempting to frame the
proud boys I should say they're
literally trying to frame them the
seditious conspiracy thing is is
ridiculous wasn't there an agent who
said they didn't hear anything like this
or what was that about yeah there were
early on and I think this also came out
because Julie Kelly was reporting on it
on Twitter
um she's amazing yeah she's spectacular
and there were some documents um
right let's do it yes
um yeah so there were some documents
from the that she had posted where FBI
agents or whatever federal agents had
said that they were with the proud boys
and that they were like embedded with
them and that they heard absolutely no
evidence of pre-plan of January 6th at
all so and so they make this up here's
the crazy and the FBI had also said that
there was no evidence of pre-planning
initially it was uh this guy Dominic
pizzola was charged with I think
trespassing parading like vandalism or
something he broke a window he broke a
window well allegedly uh and because
he's not been convicted of anything and
then
um they came later like a year later and
added seditious conspiracy and I think
the reason they did that was because
they kept saying Insurrection over and
over again and everyone on the right
correctly pointed out yet nobody's been
charged with anything related to any
kind of insurrection and then all of a
sudden miraculously Enrique tario the
leader of the proud boys conspiracy
yeah and they're I think the only ones
if you do a search like you can create
who by the way wasn't at January right
yep wasn't he in jail yeah he was I
think so
so Federal customer and you can look I
mean the doj has all of the case
documents up on the website there's like
944 cases and if you do searches you can
do searches for like assault there
aren't that many of them you know and
here's the issue right so here's the
issue bring it down to go back to
because I saw some people out there
saying well these you know these videos
that Tucker put out and this bit it
doesn't change anything because we've
seen the other videos and we've seen the
committee and we all know what happened
that day here's what is significant
about those videos and and we can talk a
little bit about because I do know
something about
um the the larger tropho videos that
that is coming by the way
um that
of those what was the number you just
said 944
944 people how many of them have
actually been charged with anything
violent anything seditious about 10
maybe 10 yeah and so the other 90 of
this are people that were walking around
that were taking pictures Norm Macdonald
had that tweet up where he said the
violent terrorists are abiding by The
Velvet ropes and statues right yeah and
and and that's exactly right and so you
can be nuanced enough to be able to say
that yeah there were you know certain
amount what uh you know 75 people 100
people let's say that that did get out
of hand and there was hooliganism right
but the vast majority of people there it
was just a crazy situation people had
the doors left open people were escorted
in
jacobsley
Goldberg saying it should be illegal to
report this stuff she also said it was
orwellian God she has this she has like
the reverse dictionary yeah so she
doesn't understand see I love I love
when they do stuff like this I did more
of it more I want more censorship of
like Goosebumps and Matilda
I want Whoopi Goldberg to just just 24
7. keep going like Keep Her On Air all
day long right because the thing you
showed me yesterday was Amber athe's
piece and spectator about politico's
banned work can we steal her too yeah
yeah that's funny Politico pregnant
persons yeah she's got a book she's got
it we're laughing as the problem's
getting worse yeah government corruption
means to me that it keeps getting worse
even though everyone keeps screaming
louder well it's it's like the whole
like it's the squeeze because there's
people are starting to notice like all
this stuff had been moving this in this
direction had been really kind of under
the radar until kovid kind of brought it
to the to kind of everyone well between
kovitz
yeah inside in their kids classrooms
everyone saw it after the the massive
what do you always say hierarchy not
hypocrisy yeah it's hierarchy that after
after Floyd was killed you know it's
okay to go protest Against Racism but
otherwise
you can't protest the lockdowns but you
can protest recently they called on
those michiganders who protested in
Lansing racist for going to the Capitol
saying that they should get to open
their nail salon
they said racist and that's the that's
the thing people started to notice that
wait a minute there is nothing racist
about going to the store and people here
and that's that's what it was normal
people having church at Walmart yes it's
like there's nothing and people started
to say hold on this is this is really
getting out of hand because this is
literally the excuse for everything now
and so I think that that that's that's a
big part of it is these things really
kind of were flying under the radar and
then it when the George Floyd riots
happened people were just like hold on a
second how how is you know leaving your
house because of covid racist I don't
get it you know well none of it makes
sense there that you know this is what
we were talking about the other day I
don't I don't see any logic to their
plan other than it's fire right we can
control combustion for a purpose like
driving a car you know we use the make
the car go forward very very simple but
uh if you don't have a control mechanism
for that that's the process I like that
but if you don't if you don't have these
control mechanism then it's just burning
everything down right so there is this
energy from the left and it is just
chaotically destroying consuming and
burning with no Rhyme or Reason
yeah I think it is doing that
um
you don't think that they have a I think
that they're looking for specific
outcomes and they don't understand that
the outcomes they're looking for are
going to be really destructive they keep
maybe maybe the young dumb dumb ones the
new executive order that Biden just put
out looking for uh to advance Equity
yeah Equitable outcomes I think the real
purpose is just to burn the machine to
the ground to destroy it all and then
afterwards who knows what you're going
to get Chinese communism or something
like that do you think they know that
their goal is to destroy everything yes
I think at the higher level
there so a lot of people think they have
this uh goal which is this leftist
post-modernist goal I I don't think so I
think they have a technocratic goal I
don't think they even know what it looks
like well I think it looks like uh covet
social credit scores Chinese communism
and they're using this post-modernism as
a as a burn a controlled burn to destroy
the system to gut it from the inside
that way they can start moving in their
their elements of social Credit Systems
and things like that well and to destroy
and to stop anyone in their way right
right so you look at Take January 6 as
not a singular event because Take
January 6 as the culmination of
everything that happened in 2020 plus
you know six days right so you have you
have covet you have Wuhan you have the
CCP you have the masks you have the
beginnings of you know we can't talk
about uh hydroxychloroquine we can and
then which became we can't talk about
Ivermectin because it's worse medicine
then then then you have the George Floyd
riots which we're not allowed to talk
about mostly peaceful then you have
antifa then you have Chas then you have
the hunter button laptop then you have
the suppression of the hunter Biden
laptop all of which culminates in
January 6. so January 6 which which by
the way you take all that together what
if that was another country what would
we call it we called a color Revolution
let me let me pull up the story we've
got this tweet from Matt Tybee the
Twitter files Twitter files number one
statement to Congress the censorship
industrial complex and he posts this
image it says quote true content which
might promote vaccine hesitancy he
elaborates in tweet number 32. in one
remarkable remarkable email the virality
project recommends that multiple
platforms take action even against
stories of true vaccine side effects and
true posts which could fuel vaccine I'm
sorry which could feel hesitancy none of
the leaders of this effort to police
coveted speech had health expertise here
you can see the information being
released standard vaccine misinformation
on your platform form and it goes on to
say true content which might promote
vaccine hesitancy viral posts of
individuals expressing vaccine hesitancy
or stories of true vaccine side effects
this content is not clearly miss or
disinformation
but it may be Mal information
exaggerated or misleading also included
in this bucket are often true posts
which could feel hesitancy such as
individual countries Banning certain
vaccines I will say right now the things
that YouTube does not allow us to say
may very well be true and they know it
and they ban you from saying it anyway
because the people at YouTube are evil
people
Marjorie Taylor green got banned for
sharing vaccine information that was
self-reported from the vares system
which is a federal database Stephen
Crowder I think got two YouTube strikes
for discussing CDC data true information
that could promote hesitancy they said
which by the way the Veris database is
the industry standard that's the one
right because that's correct and I
remember talking to someone who does r d
in Pharma for decades and and I said
well if the vares database because I
kept we kept getting fact checked right
you kept getting fact checked if you
posted something from the Bears database
and I asked a question I said well is
this true should we not use the Veris
database where do I go and they said
well of course we use the various
database what else would we use doctors
tell people that that's where they
should report it yeah the big the big
issue is from all of this
well I think we all knew but now we have
definitive proof I should say there's at
least an effort internally with the big
Tech government and this collusion to
censor real information from the
American people obviously I think
everybody who watches a show like this
and you guys and everyone who works for
or reads websites like yours or watches
a show like yours everybody knows you
know what I mean so how do we get that
information to these people who are
living in Bubble World they don't want
the information the Bubble World people
do not actually want facts they don't
want to know and when you give them the
information when you say hey actually
here's some facts they say no that can't
be because that doesn't make any sense
and it's like yeah this doesn't make any
sense you voted for these people this is
what you wanted you want to live in the
bubble now you are in the bubble and I'd
just like to say these people who are
pushing all of this stuff don't think
any of it's going to apply to them I
remember so distinctly when the ACA came
in and there were the Obamacare mandates
and at the end of the year you know if
you didn't have the proper health
insurance you got to find a whole bunch
of extra money and all of the lefties
that I was hanging out with in downtown
New York they were very pro-mandated for
the health insurance and then they all
got fined because they didn't have the
proper health insurance because everyone
was a broke ass artist right so then
they're like wait why am I getting fined
they don't think it applies to them
during the pandemic you'd go downtown
everyone's hanging out drinking whatever
the masks don't apply to them they want
to push this stuff on us and stay in
their bubble evil Vanguard they're the
banality of evil there's the finality of
evil exactly and and they know like the
random Nazi guards who are just sitting
there scratching their butts waiting
these people will gladly vote for your
destruction and oppression and then and
then just ignore the rules when it
applies to them and go out there's that
viral video from New York it's really
funny it's like this street corner with
a bunch of bars that are open and
everyone's hanging out in the street and
they're drinking they don't they don't
care at all defying all of the rules
enforce those people yeah no enforcement
this is why we call it anarcho tyranny
that's correct right so you you have
this you have people who will vote for
tyranny on those of you know so if like
okay total hypothetical but like Tim if
you or I let's say we were we were going
on a commercial flight and we had a
knife like we're done you're going to
get arrested you're definitely going to
get arrested you're probably going to
get Federal charge but we've been
swatted 15 times a year and they've done
nothing exactly we've had this studio
evacuate for three hours because of a
bomb threat right so that's exactly what
I was going to get to that if someone's
on the other side and committing actual
crimes nothing will happen to them yep
whatsoever this is the system of anarcho
tyranny which gets to what you were
saying before that the establishment is
harnessing this energy it comes from a
Tumblr and it you know originated there
and it got through the media and now
it's all you know spilling across
Tick-Tock like crazy like wildfire and
of course the Chinese Communist party is
just like boost boost boost because they
want to demoralize our society which
goes back to what you were saying Libby
that someone who's been this is Yuri
besman off right someone who's been
completely demoralized will not accept
accurate information you can take them
to Russia you can show them the gulag
they will not believe you it's kind of
Michael Knowles was on I just saw this
clip was on whatever podcast and he was
talking about how he's like yeah I I met
my wife when we were 10. we were kind of
on again off again for a while and then
we got married now we have a couple of
kids and and they were looking at him
with that like it's like the fluoride
stare right yeah
just so confused right just confused
like
like are you and then they asked him are
you joking with us are you messing with
us and he said no that's that's the
story of my being my wife you know and I
get that sometimes when I talk about
Tanya and I say we met at a Bible study
and he said okay like come on no you
didn't like you guys met on some you got
you you're a Handler knew her Handler
and then you you came and said no you
met a Bible study you've told me the
story it's very mutual I I some of the
people that were at the study still
follow us today and you know we're all
still friends Etc and so it's they
actually can't believe that these type
of things go on
because they're so used to the world
that's perpetuated by Hollywood this
hookup culture this world that's
perpetuated for example um there was
that video and and I've talked about you
know yellow stoning which is like the
new the new thing but there was that
video I guess it was a Ron Perlman movie
and he's he's walking up to a gas
station and I guess he's in the South
somewhere you I shared the clip recently
yeah and these guys and it's it's it's
footage right it's not um it's not
supposed to be real and there's a couple
of white dudes in a in a pickup truck
with a Confederate flag and he he grabs
the flag off and he says you know
something man
that offends me you know why because I
read my history and those guys were
losers and that's what you are when you
fly that flag you're a loser and he
throws it and gets in their face and
like grows and I'm like
I've never had a couple of guys at a gas
station like that a costume flying a
giant like this this world doesn't exist
except in Hollywood movies and it's
liberal left-wing fever dreams that are
perpetuated to make people think and
then of course oh that's exactly what I
would do in that situation except that
world doesn't exist no no I grew up in
the Philadelphia area let me tell you
something like the gas stations that I
was looking over my shoulder at I wasn't
looking for you know a couple of dudes
with a Confederate flag you know I've
never had that situation and I've been
all over the country I've never had this
situation happen maybe that's because
you were the dude with the Confederate
flag how about that Jack whoa mic drop
whoa whoa why look why are you check
them out why are you flag checking me
Tim why are you flag checking on your
birthday I would love to do a bit where
it's like he grabs the flag and throws
it on the ground and goes you guys are
losers and the guys just go hey hey come
on man you know what you're trying to
have a good time you know
you know I'm just getting my gas over
here well we're leaving we don't got no
trouble with you and like that's the
reality of what probably would happen
they'd be like oh yeah like what are you
doing man why are you throwing up flag
on the ground but that's the thing right
is my point is that that's how they view
fly over America that's how they view
places like Ohio places like East
Palestine where the you know just get
rid of their jobs shoot their jobs to
China who cares about them who cares
about the south they're all redneck the
only time by the way the only time that
you see the Midwest or the South
depicted in Hollywood other than a scene
like that is horror movies and that at
your like stranger things right which is
obviously hard because anyone anyone
worth anything in those places would
have already left that's the attitude
people have that's literally the way so
true that's the way that they behave
because I mean I mean I see it in the
music industry and stuff like that you
know there are some bands that are like
man I love going to the Midwest because
that's the salt of the earth real people
and stuff and then there are some bands
that really like the coasts because the
snooty you know we're better than you
people are are are like they're the
trendy bands you know right and and you
really see that kind of attitude they
really do think that the people that are
worth anything have left the Midwest
because why would you stay why would you
stay and by the way I say that as a guy
from The Cut Libby you're we're both
from the East Coast yeah I'm from
Massachusetts yeah I grew up in western
Mass like you don't get much more
liberal than that you know nothing
western Mass I grew up when I started
playing shows I was playing shows in
Northampton that's where Smith college
is wow like that's where my yeah I grew
up living like it was the 90s so it
wasn't like it is today but like you
know I'm I grew up with with as as
Progressive uh surrounded by the most
Progressive people that you could come
up with in the 90s you know those are
very Progressive people yes although I
was actually uh I was talking to this
FBI former FBI agent who was out in
Portland in the summer of 2020 and he
said that the uh when they got their
mission briefing once they got out there
the officials in Portland were like you
know but we have to live out here so
that's why we got you guys out here
we're not gonna do this work ourselves
we're very in favor of our activists we
really believe in their free speech and
when he turned in a report showing that
legal observers were actually running
cover for protesters they nothing ever
happened they like
didn't even acknowledge it that's not
Progressive anymore though no that's not
Progressive that's like tyrannical
that's that's that's authoritarian you
stop let's uh liberally so I do want to
before we before we get off gen six I do
want to to throw it out there because I
I tease this and I don't want to I want
to leave it out so this whole question
about hey what's up with the rest of the
tapes right what is up with the rest of
the team so this this plan about giving
giving Tucker access first this is
something that I've known about since I
don't know second week of January going
back so that this has been totally in
the works but what people need to
understand is that there is a National
Security review going on right now with
all of the tapes and it's not just 14
000 hours it's 42 000 hours and
it's all going to come out and every
every piece because okay from a national
security perspective I'll put on my fed
hat for here for a second right you
can't actually show every person that's
going in and out of the skiff right
because you might have people that are
in cover that are going in there that
are that are checking this out you can't
show every route that they take the the
speaker and the vice president Etc
because they're safe rooms and different
areas and things like this so they want
to be careful with stuff like that but
as pertains to the actual people coming
in I've been told that as much of it as
possible is going to be coming out
they're reviewing all of it this is from
people uh close to the speaker's office
that it's something they've they didn't
actually have as a priority coming into
uh this it wasn't like you know some
deal or something like that I wouldn't
say it wasn't a priority that's maybe
but maybe they rephrase that but they
realize how important this is and
they're actually making sure that they
can send as much out as possible and I
think that's amazing I think people are
actually going to be very happy when
they see what comes out do you know did
you see what McCarthy said today he said
because he was talking about this he
said you know uh that Tucker just had a
few
um
and that they asked Capitol Police if
there were any concerns and they came
back with one about like entrance about
like exits and things like that exactly
and then McCarthy said but it was
interesting that one that they had a
problem with Eric swalwell had had up on
the internet for the last two years
showing that part right because so I
mean this is uh you know JFK and Dealey
Plaza right to know the specific route
that a a principal is going to be taking
before they take it is an obvious
security risk for anybody McCarthy said
also that Pelosi's daughter had shown
the January 6 committee the exact route
to take from the speakers they showed
the route they showed the safe house on
Fort McNair so all of that is blown now
so now you have to completely change
that because now that's that's just
blown so if let's say you're some
terrorist group like an actual terrorist
group and you want to set up something
like this well guess what now you know
where all the principles of the US
government are going to go so as from a
security perspective the capital police
and probably in conjunction with the
Secret Service because remember the vice
president was there at the time are now
going to have to completely revamp all
that they probably have to construct
things yeah I mean some of this stuff is
is permanent fixtures in terms of how
they design for security and now if it's
out there you mean kind of like when
there was an attack at the White House
in May of 2020 that we don't even talk
about anymore yeah let's uh what did you
guys make of Benny Thompson saying that
he and the January 6 committee didn't
have access to the footage no he didn't
ask for access to the footage I think
that was BS I think it was he's that was
basically him admitting that he didn't
take the time I think I was the head of
the committee of course didn't check it
out he didn't go and look no he didn't
care none of it Adam crinzinger and Liz
Cheney and all these people not a single
one of them actually took the time to go
down and watch they were too busy
producing their prime time you know
punitary punitive special let's talk
about the uh censorship industrial
complex this is a store from timcast.com
going into greater detail on the
Congressional hearings we saw with Matt
Tybee and Michael schellenberger they
say shellenberger along with this for
with former Twitter with fellow Twitter
files reporter Matt taibi appeared
before the select subcommittee on the
weaponization of the federal government
regarding their findings in the Twitter
files quote I've never worked on an
issue where so frequently while doing it
I just had chills going up my spine
because of what I was seeing happening
schellenberger said I never thought in
my own country that freedom of speech
would be threatened in this way it's
just frightening when you get into it
it's amazing because the Democrats and
what was it that delegate woman not even
a member of Congress yeah smearing and
lying and acting like this stuff isn't
happening right before our very eyes
with Tucker Carlson he puts out video
definitively proving the police give an
escort to uh chansley the Q Shaman
walking him around the building trying
to open doors for him and the media
comes out in lockstep along with Mitch
McConnell and they all say no no don't
believe Your Lying Eyes Tucker Carlson
is speaking against the the the uh the
uh what should we call it the Enclave
right and the White House said he's not
credible that's right so don't listen to
him now we have Michael schellenberger
leave your eyes yeah don't believe your
eyes we have the Twitter files
definitive evidence that the government
was working in tandem there's portals
Twitter Twitter built a government
reporting portal and then I see this
Democrat being like was there ever any
incense where the government demanded
they take something down and Sean
Burger's like yes he's like they are
directed them take it down he goes they
did he goes they emailed saying like hey
flagging these for a videos oh they're
just flagging them though okay thank you
for clarifying you think a request is a
demand
oh I know it was insane I mean it was
actually one of the most lit
Congressional hearings yeah it was crazy
in a while it was really so Liberty we
actually watched the whole thing right I
watched the whole thing yeah I mean
anybody can tell you
yeah here we go here we go this is
Plaskett we have to praise him for his
work this isn't just a matter of what
data was given to
journalists before us now
look at questions look at that type he
gives his look to Michael schellenberger
like did she says questions about where
musk got the financing
congresswoman we know she's not she's a
delegate
you ready for this it's a clown show so
Glenn Greenwell tweeted this 18 seconds
he should have tweeted the full thing
because Matt taibi mentions he's got 30
years in the industry but it was amazing
here's what he was here's what he said
that time we spent at Rolling Stone
magazine ranking member Plaskett
um I'm not a so-called journalist uh
I've won the national magazine award the
I have still an award for independent
journalism and I've written 10 books
including four New York Times New York
Times bestsellers uh I'm not yeah there
you go right Jim Jordan in the
background just being like Oh my
goodness these people are evil there's
just there's just no question and you
know now that Ian's not here you know
what I say when the cats are away the
muscle but now that Ian's not here we
can all sit here in agreement the
Democrats are evil right yes yeah yes
absolutely and furtherance of moloch now
Ian sitting in his room going like I
should have been on the show tonight I
wouldn't I wouldn't say evilness it
wouldn't say evil you wouldn't say
withholding exculpatory evidence
I would say doing that is evil so you
don't think the people who did that were
evil I don't know I hesitate to put
judgment on a person's heart so you know
I'm a softy like so you're saying that
you're probably even Redemption yeah I I
believe in Redemption too but I got to
tell you a person who acts who engages
in evil activities is an evil person I
think they should probably be put in
prison I mean these are these are
criminals look man there's a guy who
goes into a bank and he robs it
demanding one dollar and then the cops
come and they say Sir you're under
arrest and he explains the reason he did
it was because he has cancer and he
can't get medical treatment but if he's
in prison they'll be forced to give him
medical treatment and he didn't want to
die maybe he was trans and that is not
an evil person that is that is a
horrifying story of and a very sad one
but he committed a crime and he should
go to prison you have people who are
hungry or who typically want or need
things I would not call that evil if a
guy goes to a supermarket and he steals
some food because he's hungry I wouldn't
call that evil John if a guy goes to a
supermarket and grabs food brings it out
back and destroys it because he's it's
funny and he does it in front of
starving people I would say that's evil
that's evil yeah and that person is evil
I would say that Stacy Plaskett and
Sylvia Garcia I think they are stupid I
think they are stupid moronic people I
think I don't think they even have
enough uh sense of personhood to be evil
I think they're just completely it's the
banality of you stupid like Sylvia
Garcia the Texas representative saying
useful idiots
she's out there she's talking about like
oh did you file this with Twitter first
she doesn't even know of course Ian said
the other night that he thinks I asked
him what evil was and he said strangling
a cat because you're you enjoy watching
it suffer that's an evil action do you
think a person who strangles cats for
fun is evil they go around doing
consistently knowing it's wrong if they
find pleasure enjoying it yes I think
intentionally doing what if they were
developmentally disabled and they were
laughing uh Strangling a cat is that
evil you mean like enough Mice and Men
when Lenny kills that girl I I don't
know I guess was Lenny evil I mean
Steinbeck I'm I'm mad so if a person
like does a level of intelligence
absolve someone of their evil actions
I wonder if it does that's an
interesting question I know does evil
require intelligence I do not think so I
I think whether any kind of create like
there is a degree of evil in cats that's
torture other animals for fun and
pleasure not for sustenance so but we
think we know this we know this about
them are cats evil yep I mean to a
certain degree to a certain degree they
are so I'll put it I'll put it this way
I'll put it I'll put it this way I
disagree I think they might be scampi
docs
so so I'll put it this I'll put it this
way I'll put it this way that if is is
that person evil in their heart be if
they're not making that decision
themselves of their own volition
um yes that's that's a moral question
but if you are on the receiving end if
you are someone who is subject to a
regime that's controlled by people like
Stacy Plaskett if you are subject to a a
pit bull attack from your neighbor right
then it is within your right to act to
stop the evil which is occurring to you
I just gotta give a shout out to Brett
ain't dead in the member chat saying no
cats are based and then they're posting
Focus emojis look we like cats but
there's like a degree of there's like a
hundred cats here I've watched bocus sit
outside staring at a crippled mouse that
he crippled and then it is laying there
hyperventling and shaking and then when
it when it gets up and slows us crawling
away he stands up and gets ready and
then when it runs he whacks it again and
then it just sits there and starts
shaking again oh that's that and I'm
like yo cats are evil dude that's like
that's so like horrible he's not hungry
so he doesn't need to destroy this it
was just fun because it's suffering
that's right cats do that cats I knew
this woman in college and she told me
about her dad who when their cat had
girls like that but we like cats though
because they can't hurt us and put them
in the freezer killed them in the
freezer that's evil too I think that was
evil I knew this man who was but were
they were they mentally challenged the
cat or the dad the dad I don't think her
name was Jessica but she was from New
Zealand actually so the way she said it
was Jessica I mean look when it comes to
when it comes to law we actually don't
hold someone responsible for a crime if
they are developmentally or mentally
disabled we actually say you know this
person is not capable of of going on the
stand and defending themselves the
actions they committed were outside of
their understanding so we're not going
to put them to death you know I don't
there was this woman you'd see this
woman who killed her children and now
she's her attorneys are saying well
she's mentally ill in Medicine
Massachusetts yeah so she shouldn't face
the death penalty that story man that's
brutal I think that's evil I think even
if you're mentally ill you can be evil
if I think about it in terms of mothers
who kill children I think I think people
can be redeemed I think people can be
apologetic I think people can realize
what they did was wrong but I I think
she belongs to mental institution if you
commit evil acts you are evil I mean I'm
shocked she hasn't killed herself I I
think she belongs to minerals usually
that's what that's what I'll say with
that what they did to the January 6th
defendants is definitively undeniably
factually objectively evil yes I think
that's true they withheld exculpatory
evidence violating their rights
violating the law for personal gain
causing suffering to another person well
and they did it in order to bash and
Destroy for personal gain other like
just the rest of Americans they did it
to hurt all of us they did it to
criminalize
the Trump movement and they did it to
criminalize the mega movement and they
did this as as I was saying earlier
there was a we experienced a domestic
color revolution in 2020. all the
Hallmarks of whether you want to talk
about maidan which Tim I know you were
you covered live
um whether you want to tell them about
any we're seeing elements of this into
beliti right now in Georgia
um that this was a domestic color
Revolution and some of the same people
like Norm Eisen may still be living
through elements of it uh we're we're
admitted parts of it the man who wrote
the book on color revolutions and he's
in the Time magazine article which came
out one month after January 6th like the
the serial killer writing the letter to
the police I got you and you will never
catch me uh one and then signing it
because they want credit for their work
so when I see all of these things happen
together then January 6 comes out as a
sort of it's almost like a psychological
Justice certification used by the regime
in order to say well this is why we had
to do all of those things don't you see
we had to protect you from this terrible
Movement we had to protect you from
these people these 71 million Americans
who are all domestic terrorists were
going to criminalize this movement we're
going to get rid of you that's why and
you're seeing but you actually are
seeing elements of the the symptoms of
the effects of this from the Republican
party now because you're starting to see
the more establishment types are trying
to go back to Reagan they're trying to
bring him back up again you know we're
really the Reagan party or even seeing
Eisenhower I'm seeing people do this now
like a lot of Zoomers with they always
have a Ukraine flag in their bio and
they say I'm an Eisenhower Republican
right it's like name one thing guys
Howard did and I don't know why
everybody likes Reagan so much to be
honest and then gun control and no fault
divorce I'm not interested yeah
make it harder for black Californians to
own guns well yeah like what but the
point being is but the point being is
there it's it's not about Reagan it's
about someone who's not Trump it's about
something is popular who's not Trump
that we can go back to and use as a way
to shade against Trump which is funny
because originally the The Establishment
hated Reagan they were all behind the
bush family
um and that's why you had that election
in 1980 the way you did with where Bush
becomes the vice president after running
of extremely hard race against the uh
the Grassroots populist candidate which
may be something that we see again very
soon here uh I say for no reason
whatsoever that uh
they are attempting to make it painful
and Tim you talked about this once
before you said
if you're watching the main street when
you were talking about the 2020 election
I really appreciated your your diagnosis
of what happened that you had a group of
people in this country on the left that
listened to the media and said all of
these terrible horrible things were
happening and they kept ratcheting up
the pressure rashing up the pressure
ratcheting up the pressure the pain and
the psychological torture and then said
If you just vote him out of office
but more than that they then knocked on
your door and said all of the suffering
you're enduring as you're locked in this
building is because of trump here you go
here's the bout to fill out and they say
you got it but let's talk about the
story here ladies and gentlemen one man
is standing up and fighting back for all
of us one man and that man is Alex Stein
Prime Time 99 suing Alexandria
ocasio-cortez because she blocked him on
Twitter after he called her his favorite
big booty latina and this is what it
says I'm just reading the news guys he
he said his favorite big booty Latina on
the steps she got mad she blocked him
he's suing her and uh this is is this
could be interesting because it was
previously ruled Trump couldn't block
people and if you're a public official
you couldn't block people she blocked
him now he's suing her is uh is this the
kind of culture Warrior that we need
right kind of yeah and bizarre I think
Alex Stein is really hysterical he uh we
covered this today at the post
millennial can I read you his comment
about it read his comments he said I
love and care about this country so much
that I am able to put aside my political
differences and try to come to the table
with all politicians especially AOC
because we align on more things than she
probably thinks and I want to be able to
communicate to her through Twitter
because it's the modern day digital town
hall and political free speech is the
most important protective speech in my
opinion that was all I love one sentence
and then he said I love AOC and I hope
she can find it in her heart to unblock
me
oh wow I think Alex Stein actually does
really good work in that it is it it's
it's cultural it's fun he's not even
really conservative if you've ever
listened to his actual policies he's
been on the show he's fairly moderate or
even liberal in some regards but this is
the the reason why I think the story is
interesting it's very anti-nasa if I
remember correctly yeah yeah
we argued quite a bit about how the moon
land about the moon landing he does not
believe it happened obviously wow okay
yeah yeah okay okay yeah a bunch of
globe tards out here that's what they
say globalists globalists there's a
funny video where a guy does an
experiment there's actually like 50
videos of people doing these guys doing
experiments to prove the Earth's flat
and they accidentally prove its round
and they're like wait a minute how is
this happening one guy went on a plane
and he's like because the Earth is round
the plane will have to dip down every so
often to like you know to level out
which means If he if he films this
leveler you should see the bubble moving
right and then when he doesn't see it
happen he's like that proves it and it's
like dude does not understand how it
works gravity I've been in Planes all my
life man I've never seen a curve anyway
anyway
you know people are complaining about
Matt wall saying he's too mean and I
don't even think he was that mean and uh
seeing like Alex Stein he I Alex Stein's
like a one-up on Matt Walsh I mean you
could say Matt Walsh is direct but Alex
Stein like really grinds people's gears
like he he goes in front of the
protesters there are people who hate him
yeah oh yeah I love when he goes in
front of the protesters and he's like hi
he's so here's what he does here's the
technique
right the important component that
people need to understand about what
Alex Stein does is that he doesn't
insult them he laughs says I love you
and he's too tall for them to block so
he holds the camera up and then he just
starts saying I love you you guys and
he's smiling and it drives them insane
is one of the most brilliant tactics so
if y'all are concerned about Matt Walsh
we got out Alex Stein right here but
let's be real Alex Stein pisses people
off way more than Matt Walsh does his
tactic is more uh infuriating because
it's hard to counter it he's just having
a great time there's a there's this old
there's this old movie called A Thousand
Clowns anyway at one of the the kids he
says in the in the movie he says what
are you gonna do with someone who has a
wonderful time like that and that's
exactly what's going on with Alex Stein
what are you gonna do with someone who's
just out there laughing there's there's
some there's an issue on and and
speaking as like I don't know
the right or whatever there's an issue
on the right where people just want to
be boring they just hate fun they they
and it's it's been like that for a long
time
and I don't see that I had fun but but
I've read nothing but they're very
boring and well
yeah we had fun yeah I don't know about
everybody else yeah I speak for myself I
had fun but I'm just saying in general
right there's this there's like an
aversion to fun that you can't use fun
tactics so we need we need Paul Ryan up
there talking about conch to Medicare
and Medicaid and Social Security and
physical but remember this bow tie act
that he was look look even even Turning
Point USA's event was all suits I think
the only people who didn't wear suits on
stage was like me and Ian
and and I think I don't think Dan was
wearing a suit but like everybody's
wearing yeah everybody's wearing some
kind of dress-up well that's like the
uniform man yeah but how are you like
does that does does that image attract
young people
to to want to be involved in what you're
doing and I think not really it all
depends if your suit is like you know
like a lawyer's suit that's one thing
but if you're looking like you saw the
audience rhinestone tuxedo that's pink
and Periwinkle or whatever and a big top
hat you might a lot of people are gonna
be like really excited there just need
to be more parties at these things more
parties more events McGregor looks great
when he wears a suit right like he's
walking around all you know they need to
do more fun stuff they got on O'Keefe
for being fun right they tried to go
after him about that you know I think
you know being fun and and doing music
and trying to break out of this look not
for nothing but I've been you know I've
I'm I have another job where I'm in a
band and we've been you know allegedly
we've been around for a bit and I was
putting the flag up in the early part of
the teens like hey I'm you know into
like Liberty and and I was big on Ron
Paul in 2012 and I was like looking for
conservatives that were interested in
talking about that like about my band
and stuff and nobody was nobody was
listening and the left hated me because
I was you know the left was just as as
you know as left as they are you know so
it's it's something that the the
conservatives and the right has to get
their act together on and it's like when
you've got people like the daily wire
and like Tim and stuff like that trying
to make culture the the other like
establishment right they're lagging
behind and they have been for a long
time
didn't Rogan just open a new comedy club
yeah a comedy Mothership I like that
name isn't it interesting how comedians
like I wonder if we can do a Russell
Brand or like you go to the older you
know the the Norm Macdonald clips that
are coming out or even George Carlin old
clips will come out and it's it's like
comedians have this ability to tell more
truth and actually move the needle
better than
um or Ryan long when he does stuff uh to
move the needle and actually get this
stuff across better than well that's
like with the people on the right that's
like with Alex Stein right yeah and
that's what's funny like you're if
you're having if you're laughing you
know who else is going to comment a lot
a lot easier Donald Trump Donald Trump
is funny he's very funny he's a comedian
anybody who's ever been to like him
giving a speech he's doing stand-up it's
crazy
it's great he's great up there it is it
is like George Carlin was comedy with
some politics his is politics with with
comedy but like you're laughing the
whole time it's crazy and Norm Macdonald
one of his final interviews he actually
says that it's like I think with his
sister-in-law up in Canada and he was
talking about how he actually he kind of
catches himself so Norm is in is in the
interview
and he says he's like you know I I went
to see Trump at one of these great I
mean you know not not that I went I mean
I just I just want to see what it was
like right he kind of catches himself
before he just admits going to a trump
rally I love norm and he said um he said
well I want to give see him want to do
one of these speeches and anyone who's
been in the circuit knows exactly what
he's doing that it's it's a Basics it's
it's a stand-up routine he's he's
putting on an act he's got his material
and what's great for him is that so he's
able to use whatever's going on in the
news cycle can then feed into that
um and it was even better is that so the
reporters in these if you look at it
through that framework the reporters
become like hecklers and so they're
heckling him and the of course the
greatest one of these the greatest
exchange is is you know the the one
reporter and she goes he goes all right
yeah yeah you asked the question next
look at her she's shocked she's in a
State of Shock that I called on her and
he goes I'm sorry I wasn't thinking it's
okay I know you're not thinking you
never do
excuse me excuse me no sorry to ask your
question go ahead I'll make it a good
one I went to that White House social
media Summit I was the only one not
wearing a suit in the White House oh
really you went to that yeah I was with
Bill ottman and my goodness I have so
many questions uh he just gave a speech
and then we didn't really do anything
nothing got resolved I thought there was
gonna be a real conversation like memes
like posted up and stuff yeah yeah yeah
like Twitter posts like tweets easels
and stuff like that it was really funny
and uh but we were just laughing the
whole time I mean he was doing stand-up
I mean one of my favorite things is when
he was like the lights they make me look
orange you know I'm like he just he
knows he's funny that's a huge thing
with him though because he's been doing
media for so long that before you do an
interview with Trump he will sit there
and say let me see how I look let me see
that let me see let me see the look do I
look I don't like that turn that light
off the light turn off turn this one on
turn that one off wait no angle this
down he'll do all of that because he
gets it he gets how that system works
and he knows that image is everything
yeah exactly CPAC is supposed to be the
big deal and all I've heard from people
was that it was stagnant it was boring
not many people showed up I had someone
say that 10 years ago they went you
couldn't you couldn't even get a hotel
room this time they showed up a day
right right before the event and there
were tons of hotel rooms available like
nobody was coming to it and that's kind
of worrisome I would say but there's got
to be well it's not an election year so
that's part of it still I mean there's
got to be some energy Something's Gotta
bring some energy into maybe CPAC is in
the answer maybe there's got to be some
kind of like
I don't know Coalition well it's also I
mean I will say this though right is is
that CPAC I mean I I think I mean that's
kind of what what America Fest was
basically
um
literally with music okay yeah rice and
gray five times August all about it I
would love that I was talking about
August because
I was talking to him about how he was
banned from band camp
um who Bryson uh five times August yeah
and I found you know I find it really I
know there's a ton of streaming
platforms out there it's not like you
know it's not like uh you have to just
pick one and that's the only one out
there but I do find it surprising the
way that um tech companies and culture
spaces are shutting out people that they
just disagree with and what else is not
surprisingly
has not replied to anybody did they ever
get back to you no I think we're going
to sue them
um
you know normally you never say these
things like you just filed but we're in
a different kind of political landscape
and cultural landscape so I think the
current plan is we're exploring a crowd
fund and potential class action I think
you know for us Tim guest music had
probably 25
000 sales and uh through band camp it
might be like 10 000 or something so
it's 10 000 people well the issue and
then you've got then you've got five
times August Bryce and Bryson gray
Bryson gray mentioned he was banned as
well I don't know why they've given us
no reason they have an absolute
termination Clause but I'm not sure that
matters for the people who purchase the
product they can no longer get access to
they can't yeah so the idea right now is
I'm talking with a prominent uh lawyer
on censorship issues and I said I you
know what do you think breach of
contract we've got customers who can no
longer access a product they've paid for
and we have no vehicle by which to
refund them because it went through
bandcampment bandcamp terminated their
accounts without notice so there's a
there's a problem right here now people
like hey I bought a song I can't get it
okay and uh it just breach of contract
that sounds like it for sure so they
have an absolute termination Clause they
say like we can ban for whatever reason
but that might not actually hold up in
court you can say whatever you want
doesn't mean anything so what about for
the users who pay the money well exactly
right so they still have accounts
they're still expecting to get what they
paid for and they have no access to it
to the accountant our account needs to
exist isn't this what happened they can
make an argument that we can't upload
Twitter control it but they the people
who bought the music still need to be
able to get it so long story short the
general idea is going to be to create a
crowd fund that would go directly to the
legal team not to anyone else involved
for the purpose of the of defending this
upwards of enemy I'd imagine probably
going to be in this morning
in people right it could be a class
action suit because you've got Bryson
grades fans I haven't talked to any of
these people but Bryson gray five times
August and Tim cast the combined fan
bases who purchased music through that
platform it's going to be in the tens of
thousands isn't this it's gonna be a
huge lawsuit isn't this similar to what
they did at patreon
yeah this was this was the this is the
the Owen Benjamin lawsuit yeah and there
was uh uh so so we'll see here here's
the thing I don't know I I personally
feel that they have they have breached
contract between the customers between
us they've done it for uh uh unjust
reasons they they can we can do whatever
we want whatever we want but like
you I I I'm not sure that's true so what
we're going to do is we're going to they
could say what it is and they haven't
and I think it's simply put you know
you'll often hear from lawyers they'll
say something like there's no point in
filing the lawsuit because you won't win
anyway blah blah blah well that's not
what we're hearing now what we're
hearing now from these teams is we
actually need to pursue this stuff to
figure out what the precedent is on this
kind of breach of contract but we need
the money for it so I said okay what if
we did a crowd fund and then we just got
I don't know what if we got a million
people to give 10 bucks and just put 10
million bucks in the coffers of a legal
firm to oh that'd be nice they could do
a lot with that well they could we could
then truly figure out if these companies
are are truly uh engaging in you know
civil tour violations or whatever and
then we we could actually get some
judges to issue rulings on whether or
not they are allowed to do these things
and I'll put it this way the left wants
to Sue that Baker in Colorado into
Oblivion and they keep doing it yeah I'm
down to play the same game I I'm pretty
confident that between all of the follow
the followers that I the daily wire
anybody else has post-millennial they'd
be willing to pitch in 10 bucks to a law
firm none of us will go anywhere near
that one throw 10 bucks in for that and
then like a law firm just explore
anti-censorship lawsuits that would be
amazing so I was talking we'll see where
it goes five times August too and he
started doing some digging into who the
people are that work at bandcamp and
it's a whole bunch of pronouns in BIOS
doofuses
we're making these decisions big shocker
which is exactly what we found out at
Twitter that it was all these
contractors these like third-party
Contracting you know trans activists who
were like I don't care about any of that
you can't say that that has no bearing
whatsoever on my contract with a company
and the customers oh I agree and and
that so they can believe whatever they
want to believe and maybe the reason
they took us down is political all I'm
saying is I think we need to have a
judge issue a ruling on this and it
could be simple maybe we issue a initial
you know filing and then the judge says
no look their terms clearly outlined
your agreement sorry have a nice day
okay well now here's John Smith who
purchased a song and can't get it he has
a lawsuit oh by the way here's Jane
Smith she purchased a song they're all
she has a lawsuit every single
individual who now has no access to a
thing they paid for and we have no
vehicle to refund their money anyway
well we got to figure this out so I'm
thinking we get 10 million dollars to a
law firm have them start filing away I
don't I don't know if class action
necessarily is the right approach I
don't know the rules sometimes they
force a class action I think the
appropriate thing is that some people
gave different amounts of money so
because you could give as much money as
you wanted so maybe the the best
approach is to have a bunch of
individual plaintiffs maybe three
thousand lost lawsuits filed all at once
at you know just there you go and then
we'll figure out what the uh let me just
go from there yeah yeah so we'll see
though we haven't done anything yet uh
I'm talking to a lawyer and it's
seems like there's like there's that it
seems like what you're saying you don't
want to just you don't want to just make
videos complaining about the double
standards you actually want to do
something and take it well there's
there's some other big news crazy that's
crazy you know we're gonna have to do
that we're gonna do a show on one of our
culture war episodes which is the Friday
morning show at youtube.com timcast
and uh there's gonna be a big announce
coming soon about the efforts we're
taking in defense of free speech so stay
tuned for that uh and then there's this
one which I think we we've just got we
we can't keep falling on well you know
it'll cost too much money so there's no
point in trying it's like well look I
think they breach their contract so
let's at least have a judge decide
that's what that's the point right and
even then you're you're costing them
time you're costing them effort nothing
like that nothing like that if if the
judge came out in two seconds and said
yes or no I'd be satisfied the question
is we have not gotten definitive answers
because whenever it comes to some kind
of censorship case lawyers always say
it'll be too expensive it's not worth it
you lose and I'm like okay well can we
at least try look there's no point yeah
okay what if we got a crowdfund together
well it depends on what your goal is the
goal is to to hammer out definitively
what are the rules right so then there
is a point because a baker can't can't
you know is forced to bake a cake or
whatever and they keep suing them
non-stop that is insane but then at the
same time the left says we can ban you
but you Can't Ban us I'm like okay let's
just stop arguing about it and have a
judge decide which is importantly
different argument because I was going
to say because in in all of those
instances how many bakeries did you
drive past before you found that one
Bakery there's bakeries in every single
town with the internet and the way that
it's set up in many of these cases you
have monopolies you have many natural
monopolies and this is a fundamentally
different situation that's why Elon
buying Twitter is so important because
there is only one Twitter I I have truth
I have getter I have telegram but you
know what Twitter is Twitter and Twitter
and No One's Gonna knock that off this
is the fundamental difference and this
is why you can't apply the same logic
because it is Apples oranges yeah and
it's interesting too with the left
because they're perfectly comfortable
censoring books censoring RL Stein
censoring Roald Dahl but they refuse to
allow conservatives to take porn out of
school we just had an entire hearing
with taibi and shellenberger it shows
exactly how willing there and this is a
very huge difference between the left
and the right in this country is the
left has moral Clarity and the right is
scared to argue from a position of this
is good for society well and we see this
all over the place we see this like well
we have to be a little more nuanced
about it and perhaps and it's like no I
kind of am done with that it's it's it's
ridiculous no it's it's you always want
to play they always want to play Within
the left frame they always want to use
liberal frame they want to say well use
the same stupid language the same the
same language that we're going to argue
about well I heard that one is this
Freedom or is that freedom so I'm going
to use it just just stop stop
apologizing for Western Civilization
stop apologizing Western Civilization is
the best civilization it's amazing by
the way it's the reason we don't have
child sacrifices to the the you know the
sun god anymore okay so I don't know the
sun god seems pretty pissed off lately
we didn't have winter this this year you
know so maybe some place had pretty bad
winter though some Colorado got hit we
didn't get anything we had no snow at
all my son was asking me that he was
like he was like when is it going to
snow because I want to make a snowman
you had no snow well I mean I'm only
about an hour from here so yeah we had I
mean flurries that's it I went
snowboarding and it was a brown mountain
with white strips going down it from the
snow machines did you go up in PA no we
went to uh Timberline okay because we we
drove up HPA we drove up to PA a couple
of times and it's exactly like that
there's uh there's white tail in PA I
think it's in PA yeah there's white tail
there's there's liberty there's Round
Top yeah yeah and it's like you'll be
driving through mud and then yeah it's
like mud mud mud mud mud snow but cool
cool thing though is and Olivia I know I
sent you the videos of this we actually
got four-year-old Jack Jack up on skis
for the very first time I know he and
his brother AJ are watching so Jack Jack
you did a great job skiing buddy
remember French Pizza french fries Pizza
in that uh that beaver look at his
shadow and it was supposed to be winter
for a long time or something like that
I don't remember no I think that was
Pete bootage
unfortunately it wasn't a shadow it was
the shadow of another derailed train it
was it was it wasn't his shadow
the toxic smoke that blocking out the
sun because he signed off on a chemical
attack on the Midwest and the people who
lived there because they voted for
Donald Trump and he said oh don't worry
about that we're totally fine if you and
your progeny die out because we don't
want you anymore yeah yeah they
definitely don't yeah well I think in
terms of uh
culture War issues there's there's a
couple things that need to happen and
making culture is one of the most
important things and then
lawsuits because the left is doing
lawsuits left and right of course the
right has like some sometimes the right
will sit there and complain about Mark
Elias and I and I sit there and go well
Mark Elias wins where's our Mark Elias
where's this guy oh the left is ballot
harvesting they're beating us a ballot
where's the rights about harvesting why
doesn't the right Trump said we're going
to get really good at it yeah Trump
finally and I'm not gonna be fine he did
he came out and said he quote truth to
me uh on this and I said because I said
why doesn't the right have is there
a distributed Nationwide network of
physical
congregations okay I'm giving it away
now physical congregations of
conservatives or people who are at least
center right that meet weekly perhaps
throughout the entire year in every
single state in this country that the
right could utilize for the process of
ballot collection yes and it's called
churches don't try to reinvent the wheel
ballot drop boxes in every single state
where it's legal period make it happen
every church just yeah but you've got to
increase Church goership you know I mean
there's a massive amount of it there's
there's tons of it's it's as is no but
America is like the last Christian
Nation if you tag this into everything I
know the Evangelical churches I'm
talking about traditional Latin Masses
I'm talking about
um you know Mainline etc etc right
anywhere where you can go that's willing
to do this and in this there was in
Orange County California where the
Republicans kept getting their butts
handed to them because of ballot Harvest
interesting which is traditionally
Republican area they started doing this
in the churches out there and the left
the Democrats were suing them over this
saying oh you can't do that and they
said but I mean they've been coming up
with every reason Under the Sun you're
not doing it properly that's a temporary
Dropbox and then the pastors kept
pointing out and saying but the laws you
wrote allow for all of these things
because you allow that for a nursing
home or you allow that for a grocery
store or you know the street corner in
L.A
and so and they use their own laws
against them to be able to say and guess
what lo and behold all of those seats in
Orange County flip back red I feel like
this country is in desperate need of
religion I think that's true Tim I
couldn't agree more yeah I was sort of
interested in that I know you and I
disagree a little bit on this but there
was the
the Revival in Kentucky at that school
for a minute no no I don't disagree I
think I think it's I think it exactly
shows that yearning for substance this
desperate need for a spiritual
fulfillment I think because liberation
theology that you even if you have a
Resurgence of religion you could very
easily have the same problems with
Marxism
there's significant issues we're dealing
with that in Colorado yeah right I saw
that there's significant issue with
marxists in Catholic church or not just
Catholic churches but in churches
um and it's all Liberation theology and
it it is just as vulnerable well such as
look at the pope yeah exactly he's
literally one of these guys because it
came from South America and he's from
Argentina and and what what you're
talking about though is it's still it's
a political materialist ideology that
has nothing to do with actual religion I
disagree I think I think that it's a
plant's religion for a lot of people yes
you could say it's a plant's religion
it's a it's a pseudo-religion it's like
but it's not a theology it's it's like
watching a mannequin come to life and
start walking towards you and you know
it's not a person it's like being a duck
and then seeing a decoy duck and
thinking it's a real person yes that's
what mocheness is in terms of but that's
what I'm saying it
[Music]
can we can we like co-opt the what like
can we make the symbol for weakness a
golden calf or something like that is
that offensive yeah that's a great idea
and so but my point is though that it's
it's that in in that type of religion
it's a religion based in materialism
which a true religion would not be based
in materialism right which is of course
what the golden calf was based in
correct it's it sort of is from for the
average person yes but I mean like
people like James Lindsey are talking
about uh a lot of the old religions kind
of that it's that it's kind of latched
on to and and it's so it's not so much
as secular as it's not as secular as
most people believe and it does perform
it performs the same function as
religion now though yeah but I mean it's
just there's there's been some little
Replacements right so instead of
worshiping God you worship yourself
instead of believing that you have a
soul you believe you have a gender well
I mean I don't really yeah identity is
part of it but the thing about identity
that is so important in the identitarian
movement is it's not enough to identify
as something you have to be claimed by
the others who identify as that thing as
well yeah I mean you have to you have to
you have to become you have to be
accepted as part of that group and so to
be accepted as part of that group there
are identitarian rights of Passage let's
make
that say stay woke with a golden calf on
it yeah it's not a bad idea and they
might embrace it they might love it yeah
I mean it's called the rainbow behind
them you know what it could be it should
actually not be a golden calf it should
be a golden unicorn
um yeah you like it you like the just
that I get where you're going with that
connection yeah yeah you know all right
don't give you know but sometimes but
the point that's like the point that I
would say getting the rules from God is
like what are you guys doing what is
this what the heck is this we can smash
the tablets and then that's why he
couldn't go to um you know the promised
land the way you fight Liberty this this
Liberation Theory though which which is
an issue obviously is you have to get
back to actual Orthodoxy right an actual
Orthodoxy has nothing to do with that
it's it's we will not covet my
neighbor's Goods right you should Thou
shalt not literally one of the
commandments so right there you just
beat people over the head with that that
you are not coveting if you are being
covetous if you're saying that person
has more than me and I hate that person
because they have more than me and
you're making up all the things which is
what which is grievance politics and
this this is what all of Communism is
all right all of Communism is just
attacking people for having more for
being more successful by by the problem
I want to start off a new segment real
quick
before we read this or show it I want to
ask Jack a question uh do you know the
Ten Commandments can you can you recite
them
put you on the spot man right now yeah
if if it's you know I know like you just
like get them all it's like trying to
remember every state or whatever but I I
could do that but I probably couldn't do
the Commandments but there's there
there's okay
um I'm Lord your God there's so no you
shall have no God no God before me uh
shall not take the God's name in vain uh
they're actually in sections there's the
sections about your relationship with
God there's the sections about your
relationship well I just need to I want
to read the story but before we do I
need I need you to name them until I can
until I can tell you to stop are they
father mother boom stop right there now
read the story who can read that one
Colin Kaepernick calls his white
adoptive parents racist because they
told him as a team that cornrows is
unprofessional and that he looked like a
little Thug that's why I asked you about
the Commandments because honor them thy
mother and their father yeah and he's
like no yeah so this is Dishonored this
is this is dishonest calling his parents
a racist yo dude they gave you every
opportunity they loved you talk about
spitting in their faces it's disgusting
it's completely disgusting my parents
were raised they adopted him but they
were racist total scumbag move total
loser behavior
um this is just this is something
you're you're it's it's it's clout
chasing which is all he's really done
since he lost any position in the NFL
it's just Cloud chasing he's just
punching up and it's it's interesting
because I guess his grift with you know
going after you know demonizing police
officers and going after the national
anthem has has gone on and I just hope
people look at this for what it is right
you know this guy has lost Target so
he's targeting the people that are
actually closest to him in his life and
he probably they probably were telling
him like you know hon it looks nice but
a lot of people
be professional and they weren't wrong
probably either at the time Tim you
mentioned evil earlier yeah I mean I
think this guy's evil but I think he's
the more banality of evil I mean I think
I just think it's an evil act I think
it's an evil I have to speak out against
your parents in in public but by the way
not if not if you know unless you're you
know if your parents had done something
wrong right exact course yeah obviously
but in a situation like this that were
that were you know that I'm talking
about where you have people who adopted
you
it raised you got to the point where
obviously very successful and and then
to turn around and slam them and then
use this word this epithet racist which
in our society today to label someone
racist is seen as the it's it's worse
than rape it's worse than murderer it's
this is the ultimate Evil it was but I
kind of think like they've beaten a dead
horse you know so now we're kind of just
like yeah yeah whatever you know yeah
said something really stupid that's just
sort of that was my thought when I saw
this I was like yeah of course he did
the issue more so is that he's spitting
on his parents yeah that's kind of a
crazy thing like that you know in public
people do that a lot I have parents too
like I mean not for nothing you know
like you they chose you they picked you
and you're gonna crap on them come on
yeah I mean it's also though that's what
Harry did that's like the thing that
today Prince Harry and Meghan Markle
they had like renounced their royalty
but they're like our children get to be
Prince and princesses
yeah well they demanded it they demanded
it that the children get the titles
they're the worst people they are they
they they might just be evil you know
Harry might not actually actually be a
windsor right uh
I want a browser extension I want a
browser extension that when I turn it on
it erases their names from any website
so you never have to see their stupid
simpy faces no see so well he's the simp
right so I do think that Harry Megan is
very indicative for
not just the young men out there but
also young women that this is this could
be you this could be you if you take
someone like that someone with every red
flag Under the Sun like Meghan Markle
and put her on a pedestal and put her in
charge of your entire life and all of
your Affairs give her that much of your
mental space that she will consume you
she will actually suck your soul which
we've seen or this this guy was he was a
war hero right he used to he used to go
and like party friends with his brother
you know yeah
so he hit us all of his guns he did wow
that's insane England wow yeah because
you can still have long guns in England
but I mean it's
right and then to to take someone and
have them totally control your life I
mean that divorce is going to be awful
it's gonna be a lot of them no no the
tabloids are gonna be so excited well
the templates are going to yeah
and and it's just I just think it's I
think it's sad but at the same time how
many of you have a friend in your life
that's been a Harry how many of you have
been a Harry in your life at some point
and said you know what I know they're
this way but I can fix them well I've
known I'm gonna fix them I've known some
Megan's and we've all known to Megan's
we may have I heard that she was talking
about suing South Park after they made
fun of her on that episode yeah then
they came everyone was like you are
ridiculous and then they were like no no
we're not really gonna sue them I no
we're not she cried apparently yeah I
mean so stupid she's just the worst and
I think it's true like if you're dating
someone and they say something like your
family sucks like dump that person get
rid of that person because you know
first your family then your friends then
yourself they're gonna deprive you of
everything when you when you first meet
someone check their relationship with
their family right that's right so she
she cut herself off of her own family so
her she's got half siblings she's got a
father who by all accounts and purposes
actually does love her or at least had a
good you know tried to give her as much
she could uh she throws him on the Bus
left and right then these half siblings
that she's completely cut them off I
would add Barack Obama to that list by
the way
um Who's got what how many have siblings
that you know they keep like popping up
every time you turn around by the way
shout out to Maliko
um uh and then
with with that if you've got someone
who's trying to get you to isolate
yourself from your family or your
friends just run
I was watching some TV show I can't
remember what it was was it Fringe maybe
I don't know she was on it and I was
just like well this ruined the show for
me maybe if I watched it before she did
all this stupid Shenanigans I'd but I'm
just sick of the stories like uh I'm
sick of her tears oh it's just so awful
it's really just is she like is she is
she like what is she like the most hated
celebrity probably is she because she's
like
because I don't know celebrity hi
Kardashian Kim Kardashian no but Kim
Kardashian I'm saying more favorability
I think I think probably make it work
yeah yeah she probably has way more
unfavorability in terms of the fame she
generates it's just so awful by the way
um shout out to the Alx who just texted
me the live tweets of the ubl raid what
is it it's it's it's so high affair
right here
May 1st 2011 a huge window shaking bang
here in a bada bad I hope it's not the
start of something else
and uh
uh that's it foreign
Bin Laden is dead I didn't kill him
please let me sleep now
same to how many followers do you have
Now 44 000 followers
and oh he's like a CEO he's in software
good for him yeah
so I guess uh just going back to the
Colin Kaepernick thing
targeting the reason why I asked about
the uh what is it Taylor Silverman
replied to my Alex Stein story and said
AOC needs a nice Jewish boy like Alex oh
yeah
oh yeah that's right that's right it was
so here's the point I wanted to bring up
with the Kaepernick thing is that it is
the antithesis of the the moral
tradition of this country which a
component is honor thy father and thy
mother they want to sever you from your
roots they want you to attack your
parents and one of the things we see a
lot of is kids going to college coming
back and then calling their parents
racist they're they're trying to remove
you from your family and destroy the
family so one of the reasons why I don't
think that the end goal is I can't think
of any other movements that have ever
done that in the past no right but
that's why I'm saying whatever happened
in Cambodia or China That's why when
they say our goal is this and they point
to like post-modernism I'm like no no
their goal is going to be gulags their
goal is going to be the complete
destruction of society so they can build
something different and we don't know
what that will look like and it won't be
fun that happened on The Simpsons too
the separate do you remember the one
where uh Lisa is way older and she talks
about how her dad never did anything for
her and it's like he literally took you
to the music store when you could barely
speak oh yeah and this was they kind of
like retcon Yeah The Simpsons oh yeah
what is it a new episode or something so
it was a new episode where she was
talking about oh my father never never
did anything for me he hated me he was
always against my uh my musical
um in my musical leanings
Etc and it's just not true because you
can go back to those old Simpsons
episodes and the the Crux of it was
always that you know of course Homer is
is a little bit mentally deficient and
obviously a drunk but he loves his
family and he always is trying to do the
right thing and it's it's his his
buffoonery that becomes the joke whereas
they've completely lost that because our
culture is so Hollow today when was this
episode from like last year yeah it was
last oh wow and of course age is an age
you see the one where they made Abe
Simpson gay
no the road Grandpa yeah they did it
they did an episode where what yeah yeah
where Abe Simpson ran had a friend who
turned out to be gay and then when he
found out his friend was gay ran away
and then never talked to him and felt
really bad about it and then went and
kissed him and they made out or
something oh weird they like kiss on the
lips and he was like well that wasn't so
bad or something like that there was the
one where Homer had a friend who was gay
and the oh yeah and the friend was like
Homer I have to tell you something I'm
ho yeah Mo yeah sexual what wait that
that's what the best line is like Homer
I know how to put this to you right
right I prefer the company of men who
does who does this
that was an old episode though wasn't it
yeah
the toy store there's an episode where
Bart gets mad because they're doing a
reboot of Itchy and Scratchy with a
female Itchy and Scratchy
because it's because the left that has
gotten in in Hollywood all they focus on
is deconstruction so it's deconstruction
of self it's deconstruction of story
it's deconstruction of character they do
not how to know how to tell stories
they don't understand any basic elements
of Storytelling and that's how you get
like what was it Superman had a gay son
that's why they deconstruct and redo old
stories over and over look at Star Wars
look at Marvel it's all skin suits yeah
they just go in and then and the latest
one though by the way and I mentioned it
before but it's yellow stoning so yellow
stoning is when they'll take an actor
like in Yellowstone it's Kevin Costner
in 1923 it's Harrison Ford in Tulsa King
it's it's Sylvester Stallone and they'll
put them in a film or a TV show I guess
uh Taylor Sheridan and then they'll
introduce like woke elements in the
background so they use you know the
actor and the Aesthetics to pull you in
and then all of a sudden Monica comes on
screen and she's telling you about the
the horrific abuses and genocide of the
Native Americans and then here comes a
scene in Tulsa King where they talk
about and it's not even set in the past
right Tulsa King and they'll there's
like a redlining situation that goes on
where a black guy can't buy a car who's
got cash to pay for the car by the way
and suddenly it's just like totally
unlikely super anachronistic kind of
scene is just shoved in there and
Sylvester Stallone the only way that it
would work if he can't buy the car is
because there's something wrong with his
uh you know social credit score which by
the way the guy actually was a criminal
right
I want to read this I pulled this up I
Googled it while you're talking The
Simpsons arrive in Texas to find the
Grandpa didn't actually ruin Phillips
life blah blah blah he and Grandpa
reconnect which causes Abe's feelings to
resurface he then begins contemplating
the possibility of being gay too Philip
and Grandma continue talking while
memories of the past dredge of emotions
they both shared for each other at that
point grandpa is ready to kiss the only
man he ever considered kissing then they
kiss
That's The Simpsons That's The Simpsons
from 2019. that doesn't sound great
again it's it's got It's just
deconstruction it's deconstruction of
characters so we have to we have to
deconstruct Identity we have to
deconstruct sexuality we have to
deconstruct the backstories because they
can't actually come up with a new story
yeah yeah they don't know remember when
they said Beethoven was black I remember
those
whole Theory
I did not hear this you didn't hear that
one let me see if I can pull that one up
too sort of Lucky it's like when they
say Shakespeare was a woman it's like no
the shakes Shakespeare was this guy no
definitely not he was born in Stratford
the guardian Beethoven was black why the
radical idea still has power today I
hate that there you go they did it with
Great Gatsby too
every you know article Rewritten or
whatever it will be written there was a
double Plus on good there was a a
professor who was who was teaching Great
Gatsby and he said my my students don't
understand this book they don't get it
which by the way it's it's which is
another book that is very similar to the
Harry and Megan situation it's called
like don't don't be simping right so
Gatsby was this like your favorite thing
it's my favorite thing that's my
favorite well the other one well no the
other one is uh as uh in cell of the
Opera
[Laughter]
um no so that one's not as developed but
it's it's it's it's clearly there so
he's um and what does it uh Mabel the
the girl Maple no in Gatsby oh I forget
her name I forget her name right but so
great so rather than go and find some
Zelda rather than go and find some other
girl he's got a completely change his
entire identity he's got to buy a
mansion directly across the bay from
hers he's got to and then eventually he
holds these parties to try to get her in
but but no the professor says that's not
good enough because I won't teach it as
as the dangers of simping no no no no
it's we're gonna make Gatsby black and
teach it this way which totally changes
the novel has nothing to do with what
the story was
um and sets it up in a completely
different way but this is a narrative
that my kids are going to be much more
into why is that yeah right why is that
that's because you are perpetuating
you're telling them to be you're telling
them to be where in reality
and then of course at the end Gatsby
takes the uh the manslaughter charge and
says that he was driving the car that
she drove and then hit and then killed
the guy which leads to which leads to
him dying because the boyfriend comes in
and says oh catsby was driving killed
him
are there any like prominent leftist
histories that we can retcon prominent
leftist history
lgbtq activist and family man went to
church every Sunday Angela Davis
actually descended from the Mayflower
yeah but but yeah but that story is
literally about a person whose ancestors
were raped yeah that's not like it
that's that's why I didn't go but you
can wreck on that yeah everyone's like
haha you're the defendant of slave
owners it's like you do realize it means
that they were raping them right like
that's not a good thing that bolsters
for point that it strengthens her Point
that's actually horrifying
was secretly White
he's a white European Spanish guy just
just a white guy
Charlie Gusto Charlie no I had a
professor at school
Cuban playwright right he's like and uh
he was casting Olympia ducock Eduardo
Machado he was casting Olympia Dukakis
and uh some whatever thing that he was
doing and the producers were like no you
can't put Olympia Dukakis in because
it's a she's supposed to play a Cuban
mom and so an Olympic caucus is white
and Eduardo was like I'm white I'm Cuban
I'm white yeah my family is white We're
Cuban like what do you mean like Olympus
caucus looks it looks great for this
week where they said uh that woman was
like white people shouldn't be speaking
Spanish and then someone responded I'd
like to introduce you to the entire
country of Spain
yeah it's Schrodinger's white person
it's white so they're white blue is the
English language then I always say that
like you you're saying all this in
English I don't I don't like saying
schrodingers I like we're talking about
mixed race Asians and I say Heisenberg's
uncertain uncertainty marginalized
people yeah because with Schrodinger
it's like the cat is in a superposition
of both the same time with Heisenberg
uncertainty principle it's we don't know
the point at which right the waveform
collapses so if you're mixed race Asian
we don't know at what point you're
either white or an oppressed minority so
you know did I see you use the word
quapa yes earlier today yeah what is a
quarter Asian a quarter is that as you
recorder yeah I'm a copper
I tweeted is is are you are you allowed
to be proud of being that's what they
say that's what they call it I'm sorry
and I think uh Keanu Reeves is an
October is that the colors like that
because Hapa is the others have
yeah yeah I don't know if he's if he's
if he's half I think Keanu Reeves is he
half I think he's I think he's gonna
make this stuff yeah I know right yeah
like I just yeah but my point was like
am I allowed to say quappa Pride like
what's what's right what's the degree of
white you're like to where you're not
allowed to be proud of what race you are
you know what I mean right exactly like
you're not allowed to be proud of being
Italian anymore because they tore down
Christopher Columbus and not in
Philadelphia he sucks and yeah Italian
no Phil in Philadelphia we had a little
bit of a different response when they
tried to take down the Christopher
Columbus status
the boys came down surrounded that
statue and said nope my brother was
there yeah and it was uh it it got a
little dicey shall we say you know it's
like you're not taking Chris so why
don't you get out of here you're not
taking Chris Christopher ain't going
nowhere
all right let's go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
Channel and for my birthday head over to
timcast.com and click that join us
button and become a member because we're
gonna have a members only uncensored
live show for all of you they go up at
about 10 10 p.m once it wraps it's
archived you can watch it at your own
Leisure whenever you feel like watching
it and uh you can follow the show at Tim
cast IRL Let's uh let's read what you
all have to say here
all right the the coding chicken oh
interesting it says happy birthday Tim
hope you had a great day and spent time
with friends and family I grabbed it it
was fantastic lovely yeah Cassandra got
me a pie cake
I think it's called
Pike it's it's cheap it's a pie on the
bottom cheesecake in the middle and then
cake on top it's amazing that's really
bizarre yeah I had I had crab dip uh
quesadillas the other day oh crap oh my
goodness that sounds so good amazing it
was amazing it was it was literally
amazing I want that happy birthday Tim
all right
Squirtle guy says I don't have the money
for a membership on YouTube and the site
when will the app be available so uh the
app is like ready to go the issue is
Apple has like a security protocol I
guess so like the app's been done and I
don't I don't know what's going on I'll
put it this way unless I directly do
everything myself it stagnates
for whatever reason it's hard to
delegate tasks to other people because
there's only so much people it's a
combination of factors but one if I have
to sign off on something and someone
else can't then everything slows down
but uh yeah I don't know what's gonna
happen and uh we'll we'll see how long
the app lasts on the App Store because
the first one we're rolling out is the
iPhone app and I got a feeling they're
gonna be like no really why like what on
What basis I mean bandcamp didn't give
us any reason it's a culture War yeah
you know you best start believing in
culture War Stories you're in one Libby
Libby you still think these people need
a reason
yeah they're gonna be like we don't like
your face so get you up and get out of
here and we're gonna be like hey yo oh
what am I what am I doing huh gonna be
like you see that beanie I find that
beanie offensive no but they let truth
social they're gonna like why do they
let truth truth on and they wouldn't let
yeah that's true that's true and all it
really is is kind of like a round of
lawsuits well you know we'll see we'll
see
all right what do we got hillbillary
Clinton says happy anniversary of the
day of your birth I'm already a member
but here's some extra Casino money love
you bro don't worry we have put in the
order for the poker table for our poker
with the boys new show we're doing
you got to come down Jackson be fun
let's do it and uh we're getting the
RFID table so when the cards are dealt
you put them down in front of you and
the computer live stream will already
know what cards you have oh that's
amazing and display them on the screen
and then you can look down the computer
knows before you do so the idea for the
show is poker is mostly the backdrop the
idea is to just Friday nights after the
show we hang out play poker maybe I
don't know maybe we'll do cigars depends
on what our insurance allows for it's
really fun yeah and the joke was that it
spoke with the boys so if ladies show up
we're gonna make them wear fake
mustaches yes oh I love that and then
you know yeah talk like this I'm just
one of the boys you know it won't be
like that's right no ladies in here and
then we all high five you can get glsen
to send chest binders no I'm kidding but
the the general idea of the show is just
a hangout podcast while we're playing
poker because it makes it fun and silly
like we're playing a game of some sort I
should have to draw the mustache on with
a marker
with the fingers
yeah you have to do this if you're a
female you have to have the the finger
mustache I love it it'll be Like That
Seinfeld when they went around with
mustaches you remember they were like
what are we doing and so we're we're
very like that that may be something we
launched very soon the only thing we
need now is the poker table and so we
got a company that's putting it together
uh there's gonna be a shuffler there's
gonna it's like a mushroom shape almost
where everyone sits sort of like in a
semi it's gonna be like a casino table
it's a special it's a table designed for
for for shows so so ins so typical poker
tables are you know oval or around yeah
yeah this one's like more like a
mushroom top so that the people sit
around half of it so there's blocking
for the camera so the cameras can all
point and then everyone can still see
each other it's like a half moon
basically
but it'll be fun and then we're talking
with uh Clint from liberty lockdown to
host it once a week Friday nights after
IRL we come downstairs in the studio and
we sit down and we just hang out and
everything's all set up and ready to go
that's great and then we direct all the
viewers to go watch the after show where
we hang out in smack talk and since you
don't have like The Afters on Fridays
anyway it's perfect timing and then it's
a chill Friday night where we'll have
beers drinks soda chips nachos crab dip
and people will be you know playing
around and lying to each other and
having fun that sounds fun I'm super
excited for that it sounds like it
sounds like it's not even work sounds
like I want to come hang out oh and the
winner gets the super chance so what
we're going to do is we're going to
everyone gets a set number of chips
tournament style and then at the end of
the night the winner will get whatever
the Super Chat number is so we'll be
like you won and it's like oh it's like
a thousand dollars congratulations and
there's some locals out here who play
who are really funny that I'm really
hoping we could get to come on oh
that'll be really fun there's some
really funny guys I love this idea yeah
I'm super excited for it
all right jazzanat says every day you do
your show is like a birthday for all of
us we're grateful for what you and the
team do we look forward to each day so
happy birthday Tim Q pro wrestling you
deserve it chant wait imagine how old
you would be if your birthday was every
day though I know you'd be really old
yeah I'd be thousands of years older
crazy
did you guys ever Mark when you had like
your ten thousand ten thousandth hour
like I've been alive for ten thousand
hours well a lot I remember doing that
for days yeah I remember I once
calculated like the average of how many
days I would have left to live well I'm
halfway there yeah yeah so uh you know
I'm I'm 37 now that's kind of crazy wait
you're ha if you're halfway there then
I'm less than half that's right well the
life expectancy for the average male is
what 72 wrote about the average quappa
is it 72 with the average quappa
probably higher so actually in my family
it's way higher yeah yeah yeah the the I
do think there's an Asian component of
living longer uh there's there's two
factors to consider these Asians on on
average do live longer and I'm wealthy
those two things will help you yeah it's
true that no joke it's true I mean like
when when you have money you like it's
it's a it's a it's a it's a it's a fact
you get dental care when you need it you
get medical treatment when you need it
and you know I've always been pretty
Lefty so I'm not out there digging
potholes or whatever exactly I'm not you
know aside from skating I'm exercising
I'm eating well it's it's very easy for
me to be healthy relative to the average
American so my great grandmother
recognized my privilege yeah
my great grandma 108 when she died it's
amazing 108. you're gonna live forever
well you know here's hoping you know
both both uh didn't I know Trump's
father lived into his 90s and I think
his mother lived to be like 89. oh
really yes he's gonna be around for a
long time my my other Grand my
grandparents died in their 90s wow all
of them yeah all right so basically
every Super Chat is saying happy
birthday and I really do appreciate it
that's very sweet you did kind of ask
for that all right Noah Sanders says
Jack please School Tim on Vivek he keeps
bringing him up but I know you've been
following him and his team closely promo
code Tanya on my pillow well wait you're
gonna throw out a promo code Tanya which
is a conspiracy theory by the way and
then after you ask me to do something do
not try to use promo code Tanya no one
should ever use promo code why would you
do that why would you why it's your
birthday why would you do it
look look Tim I was gonna be all nice
now and I was gonna give you I was gonna
where I was to give Tim pool
on my pillow too for his birthday and
now that I hear that you want to use Pro
is going to make it a whole thing it was
going to be like um you know for to my
buddy Tim give me the sticker right
there you know use it on the thing and I
I don't know now I don't know Place
pillow and dryer for 15 minutes before
first use this is my pillow is very
advanced technology do not let the
Chinese get a hold of this Tim you
remember the uh the our pillow that we
had here our pillow I don't because I
only remember my pillow it was a burlap
sack full of uh styrofoam packing
peanuts how about that and that and
David Hogg we we planned this whole
thing out we never actually were able to
pull it off but the idea was and we
should I guess the idea was you open up
the box and it's Pat it's a burlap sack
buried in packing peanuts with a card on
top
with ikea-like instructions on how to
set up your hour pillow and it's like
the Communist version of the pillow it's
like very low quality garbage styrofoam
packing peanuts and a burlap sack very
uncomfortable and Scratchy and then
there's like a little man like pouring
the peanuts into the bag on the thing
and like a picture of him pouring the
penis in his mouth and then going I was
like a circle with a line through and
all that stuff we I was I was like the
idea I had was
to do that I even called Fox News and
said can we run a commercial and we I
talked with their ad department they
said absolutely I explained the goal of
the commercial would be a a Soviet
Russian sounding guy explaining why our
pillow is better and that you have to
use it and sacrifice and accept how
awful the pillow is for the good of our
comrades
on you well it's just like you know
every so here's a funny thing I've got a
Soviet handgun
and it sucks and nobody ever wants to
use it at the range because it hurts and
that's like very Soviet it doesn't
matter if it hurts you as long as it
works it's cheap and you can Mass
produce it so that's like the idea of
the our pillow that Soviet Cosmonaut
that's where I shoot sidearms wow yeah
you never know it's going to find in
space no no the idea was because when
they landed
um they were always
plan the plan was always that they would
land in Siberia with their capsule and
then so they just in case they were
attacked by bears that they would give
the they would give the cosmonauts and
they even developed a a special gun just
for this purpose so that they would if
they landed in in Siberia and you need a
handgun to kill a bear as you would have
that I'm I'm genuinely excited for the
most Russian are you gonna put it in the
dryer first yeah literally as soon as we
wrap up I'm gonna put throw in the dryer
but you gotta do it I want a review it's
going to be nice well I had I had the my
pillow one like a year or two ago a
couple years ago yeah I think we lost in
the mood to be honest uh I don't know
what happened so you needed a my pillow
to begin yes there we go I actually
thought it was fantastic but what I like
doing is taking a regular pillow with a
my pillow on top that's that that was my
jam I thought it was fantastic I'm just
all my pillows just uh it's 50 of them
it's all my pillows didn't we didn't we
talk about filling up a room of my
pillows
and then you know like yes yeah we're
gonna we need to do that maybe maybe you
know oh yeah we talked about that
because the the new studio we're
building is has got like a recreation
space right and we were like instead of
doing an airbag we should do a pile of
my pillows yes that would be awesome and
then an airbag so like we have airbags
outside so when you when you uh you can
land on them oh for skating yeah so you
can launch up in the air and and you
land in an airbag if you fail and fall
you bounce in an airbag if you land you
can ride off the airbag because it's
it's pressurized so you can still move
on it so we wanted to do
um a foam pit
foam pits are designed so you can try
and do dangerous things and land in a
phone but you don't get hurt so if you
want to learn how to do a backflip or a
front flip instead of foam though we
should just get a bunch of my pillows
yes and then have a my pillow pit
exactly that sounds really funny yeah
and then you can jump off the 20-foot
tall Studio building into the pit of my
pillows if you're brave and you can do
like the razor's Edge to your brother
bam I'd be scared drop them in there
I've done I think like a 15-foot drop
into a foam pit once wow it's scary yeah
it's very scary but you just I've done
like I'm true you know I've fallen into
a foam pit and those things are hard to
get out of just from like a half a foot
I got stuck in one Charlie had to help
me out
all right let's read some more we got
Bunga Hooch says in the realm of
creating counterculture it's important
that we create media for younger
audiences as well as older ones I plan
to launch a webcomic by the end of this
year to do just that happy birthday by
the way I appreciate it
all right
Adam Atomic storm says hope you read hot
dogs up for poso he'll know at what
point do we protest in front of where
they are holding the j6 political
prisoners who's passive Injustice who
said that about the hot dogs no hot dogs
absolutely not I am tracking every
single one of you with these and I I
just I just remembered too that other
guy asked about Vivek and wanted you to
talk about him he did yeah I did the
political thing right where I changed
the subject it was very clever it was I
know uh so no no I mean I just I I think
when I hear like America First 2.0 it
just it strikes me as like well this
just seems a lot very similar to like
the Paul Ryan Mitt Romney stuff just
rebaked over again of you know magic
dirt and we're gonna increase
immigration or be strong on National
Security it just kind of sounds like
going back to the old style of things
I'm gonna I'm just looking at these
slippers real quick what is this all
season men's slip-on slippers and it's
like I I remember when Andrew Yang was
on the left and everybody said oh it's
gonna be you know he's gonna be the new
thing and it's gonna be great and it was
just like flash in the pan and then
totally disappeared I don't think
there's a lot of I honestly as much as
ever there's a lot of talk that people
like to talk about uh third parties or
or new parties or I I just don't see a
realistic place for him you know I mean
even even with Maga as kind of the the
I guess the heart of the Republican
party now this goes the thing to a third
party that we have in America yeah I
mean it just seems just within the
Republican party yeah you know because
of their dismay really yeah obviously
wonderful but even that like the Maga
the Maga party or the mag of wing of the
Republican party is attractive to some
Libertarians you know some of the the
the the the
less whoa the non-establishment
Libertarians I think I mean I think I
think there's a lot of issues of overlap
there I think foreign policy obviously
um you know very simpatico in terms of
like it was you actually saw uh Matt
Gates Right who's like the most probably
the most
um Republican member of Congress right
now come out yet was it yesterday and
put up an amendment to pull our troops
out of Syria right an argument that the
old party never would have made one
which to their credit the squad all
agreed with yeah
um and so now I'm not saying that
there's Libertarians out there that are
furiously typing right now all you
Anarchist Libertarians take it easy all
right I'm not saying that that I expect
anarchists to be Republicans or anything
so yeah but but I think there are a lot
of issues uh there's that there's issues
like Bitcoin they're dealing with the
FED uh dealing with the you know just
understanding inflation and and the
pressures of that
um I think there are obviously issues
where we you know we would disagree
right and that's probably more than on
social issues but it you know gun issues
ETC like I think there's a lot of issues
of overlap yeah
I was just going to say I I was on the
website I put in promo code Tanya and it
made the slippers basically free no no
that's that's that's a that's a glitch a
common glitch that occurs but you know
25 bucks when you go to check out it
actually just like like a hand reaches
through the screen and slaps you around
a little bit so you definitely don't
want that you definitely don't want to
use Pokemon all right Corey Alexander
you were actually sitting there doing
promo code Tanya yeah yeah I was trying
out to see if it was real or not I
figured it was it worked she's watching
too Corey Alexander says please read
this for Phil I think it's time that you
get compared to the likes of I Lane
stale Chris
Weidman for your unique voice lyric
subjects and song structure time to join
Legend status uh well I appreciate that
uh Lane Staley is a is definitely a
Legend
um he was the original singer of Alice
in Chains for people that aren't aware
um so I appreciate it thank you very
much for the the vote of confidence and
and thanks for listening it was funny
when I was growing up in Chicago the
only thing they ever played on the radio
was Stone Temple Pilots non-stop over
and over is all they did and now that
I'm older like I would get so annoyed
when they would play the same songs over
and over again I'm like play something
else but for for 15 years nothing but
Stone Temple Pilots Everything song yeah
on the radio that's right q101 in
Chicago and then uh now I'm older I'm
like I turn the radio on my car and I'm
like look at the Stone Temple Pilots on
here all right let's play that rip Scott
Weiland man I saw him like so I'm like
five or six times with the pilots and
his you know Velvet Revolver and some of
his solo stuff like having galoshes and
I just I remember like I definitely was
not happy when when he died and same
with with Cornell Lane Staley
um but shout out to Scott Stapp because
because yo I'm telling you go listen to
a couple of Creed songs right now if you
can after you listen to the third hour
obviously
and so and it's the same situation
remember Creed was everywhere yeah Arms
Wide Open the mid-2000s everywhere and
everyone's like ah come on come on yo
go listen to it again Adrian Curry says
q101 sucks she is completely
yeah and then when it's like Creed is
Creed is is due for a comeback totally
due for a comeback agreed all right cam
girl as soon as I got a table at your
Austin show however the others who were
coming with me had to cancel I'm still
planning to go but find myself with
three extra tickets know anyone who
might want them maybe do a giveaway let
me know
I would not coordinate that honestly
um
so I have no idea maybe you could shout
out something on the chat so people
could get in touch with you and then you
could uh share the tickets or something
that's very cool to like throw it out
there to everybody
Marvel win says happy birthday Tim you
and my grandma share a birthday she's
101 today wow March 9th is the best
birthday it is the peak of Pisces
just so just so you guys know
Pisces is uh I was told that you uh uh
start your first life as an Aries and
then every time you get reincarnated you
move down the the you know
the the astrological chart or whatever
zodiac the Zodiac there you go and then
Pisces is your last life so that's it
I'm out you know oh you're done yeah
after 72 years old I'm sure and then I'm
I'm off so this is your punishment for
all your other lives I have no idea
maybe yeah what's your punishment go
wherever the pagans go when they die
what what do pagans think happen when
you die is that it you I think you just
described it yeah okay I think that is I
don't know what happens afterwards you
can make it's a tree yeah
short story about this woman who uh for
her punishment for doing some crime she
was planted in the park and she turned
into a tree
it's like a story yeah a legend yeah
it's like a i for a good while I was
obsessed with Japanese literature and
this was one of the stories I read yeah
but I don't speak Japanese So eventually
I was like I know I'm missing so much
this is ridiculous I did the same thing
with Norwegian literature and I was like
what is up with these languages I'm
never gonna know them if you are you are
Norwegian though right uh yeah I'm a I'm
a quarter what is it is there a word for
a quarter Norwegian region
all right Juan Road says mental illness
versus evil look up Richard Chase the
vampire of Sacramento
oh that's crazy
will it give me an opportunity to use
the word exsanguinate because I like
that word like it it's a great word yeah
it's a great so it's a word you get to
use in rare circumstances just like
defenestrate right yeah that's a great
one right decapitate well decapitate
people use all the time crashes yeah but
Defenders yeah that's a good one yeah
I've always said the defender Street
sounds like something different than
what it's actually describing right yeah
yeah I want you to explain I
defenestrated him oh my gosh oh no it
sounds like you removed something yeah
you're removing some because it sounds
like decapitate or sanguinate but why
why is why is there a word for those
that don't know it means to throttle
window but like why is there a word
because this is the English language we
get to have a whole bunch of crazy words
we get to have like a like a bunch of
different words yeah shout out to all
the ESL folks out there you know my wife
one of them because it is just yeah the
English language does not have any Rhyme
or Reason to it can we get a word for
like
flushing down the toilet
I guess you say flush yeah
but like you never say you would say
flush it down the toilet so yeah so we
need a word like deflationator did what
like Tylenol
the determinate I'm sure the Germans
have a word for it one very specific
makeup word makeup make up our own words
the words get invented anyway you know
I mean words get invented all the time
it's kind of weird they kind of just
happen people know what they mean
until they intelligence tells you that
they have to mean something else well
that's slang right so that's slang so
like you know go read 4chan you'll find
lots of words on there that nobody knows
about well humanitis was a slang word
and then they eventually get humongous
right and they eventually get normalized
also slang yeah they become normalized
and then they become teddy bear uh
cromulent and ambigan were invented by
The Simpsons as jokes in other words
yeah and bigen is definitely out there
that was big and Noble spirit and
Biggins yeah yeah uh what is it a noble
spirit and biggest and biggest the
smallest man
[Laughter]
all right let's see the Meep kids says
conservatives have always been fun but
the neocon and Neo neolibs repressed
them that's fair maybe gotta bring the
fun back it's time to to the
conservitarians or or yeah so that's
such an issue why don't we put on an
East Coast
convention that's actually fun
what if we did like a what if we did
like a big Music Festival
or a culture a big culture yeah like a
whole big Festival where it's not even
about politics
we'll get a floor like a big convention
floor space where vendors can be and
you'll have music producers let's do a
big outside you'll have the mic the my
pillow fluff pit that would be really
funny awesome and then you climb up this
post and then you jump off from like 10
feet into the pillows or or even better
we could have instead of a dunk tank
it'll be like yeah
right so and like we could all take no
but we could all take turns no no you
wouldn't suffocate you would just you'd
fall and then you you could take turns
on who's the person in I had a better
one for you the my pillow pillow Arena
okay and it'll be like a wrestling ring
thing yeah just straight a pillow
fighting yeah pillow fight would be I
would have a lot of lawsuits with that
wasn't there was that that twitch thing
they tried something like this and oh
yeah well that was because they put foam
cubes on the hard concrete ground and
and like it wasn't a foam pit someone
broke so this woman she jumped and
landed on her ass but she landed on the
ground she like broke her back yeah
yeah don't do that yeah don't let's not
do that
but it would be cool like you go to
VidCon and they have video games they
have TV shows they have this big floor
and then they have the convention rooms
we just need something like that for
culture that we want to do so we used to
hold I think we used to put on events
and we know some rich people don't we
come up we oh you're just talking about
what you were right
so what we're going to call somebody you
buy tickets
what we found though is that people want
different experiences so there will be
people who like just legitimately want
to see a panel right they want to hear a
panel talk or they want to see to see
someone give a speech but then there's
other people that are like I want to
wail on somebody with a my pillow I just
want to do that there's other people who
want to network there's people who want
to drink there's people who want to do
different things and so a good
convention would cater to all of those
things at the same time and you could
you you would you would have that outlet
that's going to attract people let's do
it I'm in yeah let's do a big cultural
convention let's figure it out
conversation couch you know yep so stuff
invite Libs so here's the it would just
it wouldn't be political just be
controlled by people who don't want the
weird garbage and media and anyone can
buy a ticket yeah yeah and so you know
what do we have like the freedom freedom
Fest TP USA stuff it was great but it's
very political it's all political then
you have cpex all political we need
culture I agree we need Tom McDonald to
perform on stage in front of you know 10
000 people in the convention center we
need
John Rich absolutely five times August
you could call it uh call it nauticon
let's do it let's figure it out because
um I think I think you have some
connections with some billionaires maybe
some former president billionaires I
don't know what you're talking about the
many things I I don't know because
certain people might be uh might be tied
up while they're sitting as the 47th
president of the United States that's
true that's true but I do think um I've
been having comments Joe Biden said
today a lot of conversations about
cultural stuff and you know like I was
talking with cash the other day about
doing some kind of cultural Grant where
once a month we give 10 grand to
somebody who's working on some kind of
culture and cultural Endeavor I love it
and uh he agreed and said he knew some
people probably get on board he's got
the non-profit already so I'm like let's
figure this one out that could be
awesome
maybe as a component of that we do a big
cultural convention at the end of the
year we bring that's a great idea like a
little bit aspenation and I'll throw
this out there
as a parent too by the way there's such
a need for Content that is not woke for
kids and I'm not saying it has to be
like Veggie Tales and you're like
beating people over the head with with
Bible verses in scripture I mean just
like normal good clean shows and content
that are out there that's that's new and
fresh but even like even miss Rachel is
going woke right that that all of these
different you know kids
content you know like that then you've
got blippi who's just obviously like a
freak
um and some of these other people out
there that are in this space well I mean
go look at his original videos like I'm
not even going to say it here but just
go look at what he got famous for
originally or tried to get famous for
you know I'm talking about Serge
um that just disgusting stuff and you
just I don't know what's wrong with you
with people that they haven't developed
sort of a sense where they can look at
somebody like that and say okay an adult
trying to act like a child and dressing
like a child there's something wrong
with that so I want something that I
could show my kids that's just fun that
they're gonna like and they can learn
like colors and stuff well and it's it's
interesting too what you say about the
cultural Grant because a lot of stuff
really started changing when granting
organizations were specifically giving
money for identitarian Content yeah and
we're kind of like BlackRock and
Blackstone and Vanguard and State Street
started promoting Investments and
credits for investment in your company
based on those same exact
characteristics
yeah tune events.com so uh I don't know
you guys as bandcamp has an arbitration
Clause with users sure yeah we'll let a
judge decide like we'll file and then
when when it goes to a judge and they
say oh there's an arbitration Clause
that will mean bandcamp files their
response but that's what they did that's
exactly what they triggered with patreon
was arbitration yeah yeah so they can so
they can respond for every single 35 000
times of arbitration
yeah I mean for every customer that
they've reached contract with we'll make
sure a judge decides because a judge
might say in the wake of 35
000 arbitrations
arbitration doesn't make sense right and
so this is a thing that any dispute
arising will be settled by arbitration
sure sure but what happens when the
court is looking at 35
000 complaints they're gonna say no no
guys we can't do that that's too much
this arbitration is not going to work
they're going to do something else so
I'm not saying I disagree with it I
don't care where it goes I'm just saying
we have to take step one which is send
the filings to the courts and say we
believe this is a civil tort violation
for these reasons and then the judge can
say yes or no but this idea of sitting
back and doing nothing and going oh darn
they've done it again it's just not not
working it's not feasible yeah
Donald Dixon says top five guests
Michael malice Jack however you spell
that Crowder and Luke can fight with a
potato man for fourth and fifth
oh Luke and Luke can fight with the
Piano Man for fourth and fifth well the
potato man's not here although I do
recommend watching the latest Freedom
tunes cartoon because it's really good
and I of course into that voice of Dr
fauci in it all right let's uh we'll
grab uh it's just you know I I a lot of
the super jets are you know people
saying happy birthday so I don't want to
make people think like I'm not trying to
find good ones but I do appreciate it
I will read one more
because reason says the my pillow pit
2.0 could be like new Disneyland just
saying amazing all right everybody are
you saying my pillow land my pillow oh
that's actually not bad oh totally if
you haven't already characters smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends and go over to timcast.com right
now and click that join us button sign
up to become a member it's my birthday
do it for me the one time of year I get
to pull that pull that one off say oh
it's my birthday you got to do it right
but we're gonna have a members only show
live in about 10 minutes we're gonna
wrap this one up then go live on the
website where we are going to be
uncensored and not so family friendly so
check that out you can follow the show
at timcast IRL you can follow me
personally at timcast Jack do you want
to shout anything out uh human events
daily is the podcast if you want to
subscribe we're on every day I will be
on immediately after this because it's
pre-recorded for today we're going
through these this Gen 6 I'm going to go
through all the emails that the FBI
doesn't want you to read we're going to
be asking questions about this this
family quote unquote that was it was
taken hostage in Mexico and was that
really just a tourist trip like they're
telling us and uh we're going to get
into some of these political and words
right on
I'm Libby Emmons I am the
editor-in-chief of the post-millennial
and at human events I work with Jack
every day and I already listened to the
pods now it's crazy it is crazy that's
just so nice
there you go it is kind of nice but
congrats by the way congrats on being
named editor seriously editor-in-chief
of human events human events existed
prior to a National Review prior to all
of these things it was the original you
you were in a long line uh going back to
the 1940s honestly uh which is amazing
been having a lot of fun with it we've
been turning out some good content it's
been really exciting awesome uh I am
Phil Levante uh Philip remains on
Twitter Phil that remains official on
Instagram uh yeah
on Twitter please argue with me there uh
it was a fun one glad to have you back
and Libby all right everybody we will
see you all over at timcast.com in about
10 minutes thanks for hanging out